hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his piece the subject and power
michelle foucault asks a question and
actually makes it the title of a section
how is one to analyze the power
relationship and this is an important
question
as usual foucault will begin by telling
us how not to do it so with some
negatives but they're not entire
negatives they're more
warnings not to over invest in one
simple solution or another and then
he'll give us as he so often does a
listing with explanations about what we
should be looking at and then he
concludes with a few other
clarifications about in this case the
state or the nation state as we
typically call it so he begins by
talking first
about power relations
and institutions now this is interesting
because
vuco is often read as focusing almost
exclusively on institutions and i think
a surface reading of
his early and middle works would
certainly give you that that idea but if
you look more carefully that's not all
that he's doing
and he says that um
here we go we can analyze these
relationships or it's perfectly
legitimate to do so by focusing on
carefully defined institutions why they
constitute a privileged point of
observation diversified concentrated put
in order and carried through to the
highest point of their efficacy and he
says that it's here that as a first
approximation
we might expect to see the appearance of
the form and logic of their elementary
that is power relations elementary
mechanisms but he goes on and says
the analysis of power relations as we
find them in certain closed institutions
presents a certain number of problems
and he's going to identify three of
these
in particular so the first one
focuses on reproductive functions what
do we mean by that well every
institution
tends to maintain itself in existence
and not in a static way you know it like
a rock or something like that there's a
lot of different things happening within
an institution that makes sure that it
continues on you know financial economic
matters
dealing with difficult cases
of you know decision making thinking
about the future all of these sorts of
matters are what he calls reproductive
functions and so he says the fact that
an important part of the mechanisms put
into operation by an institution are
designed to ensure its own preservation
brings with it a risk what's the risk of
deciphering functions that are
reproductive
especially within power relations in
institutions so we might focus too much
on how institutions keep themselves
going and not all not enough on what
else is going on within the institution
the second is a little bit more
problematic he it's sort of a curt
before the horse as we say or as he's
going to say explaining power
by power
power relations are something that do
exist within institutions but not
exclusively within institutions and so
by focusing on institutions as our
central idea
we can sometimes fall into the trap of
thinking that everything is an
institution this is very common with the
misreading of foucault as saying
everything is a prison right which is a
cool thing to say but it's clearly wrong
actually he says that's wrong in this
very essay and so that that's an issue
and then the third thing that he points
out he says
insofar as institutions act essentially
by bringing into play two elements
explicit or tacit regulation so that's
one element and an apparatus another
element one risks giving to one or the
other an exact exaggerated privilege
that is focusing on it too much
in the relations of power and then
seeing in the latter
only modulations of law and coercion so
looking at institutions as being
essentially coercive
rule-bound and not looking at them as a
place in which power relations play out
and can be structured and all of that
sort of stuff so he reminds us of what
he said earlier in the essay about power
relations he tells us that power
relations are modes of action on actions
right so this is going to have some
implications also for institutions he
says institutions are important but we
need to analyze them from the standpoint
of power relations
rather than vice versa so how how do we
do that well we'll get to that in a
moment
before that he tells us power relations
as modes of actions on actions
are as he calls it rooted
deep in the
social
nexus not a supplementary structure
over and above society whose radical
effacement one could perhaps
dream of there is going to be no actual
society civilization culture institution
whatever you want to say no
human way of existing with others
that does not involve power relations we
can imagine those
but only so far because as he says
any society without power relations is
merely
an abstraction
so this is a very interesting point of
view it's not to say that every society
therefore sucks or is terrible or
something like that
every society does have power relations
and we need to
look at power relations without
automatically assuming that power is
something bad or scary right
so he goes on and he tells us to live in
society is to live in such a way that
some can act on the actions of others
so
this he says makes it all the more
politically necessary the analysis of
power relations in a given society their
historical formation the source of their
strength their fragility what he's
saying here is listen as members of
post-enlightenment late 20th century in
his case our case
early 21st century human beings
we do need to look at power and to do so
in ways that don't blind us ahead of
time to what power is and so he's going
to offer us here
five main
as he calls them points to establish
these are ways that we ought to
look at ways we ought to carry out the
analysis of power and each of these is
connected to the others as he's going to
say so the first is what he calls a
system of differentiations
that permits one to act on the actions
of others who gets to
do things who gets to decide what others
possibilities are and to
you know not necessarily determine the
actions of others but certainly
condition the actions of others and it
gives you some examples of this
juridical and traditional differences of
status or privilege we're all familiar
with those economic differences in the
appropriation of wealth and goods right
it's different if you're rich or poor or
in the you know amorphous middle class
linguistic or cultural differences these
play an important role not always
exactly the same from society to society
differences in know-how incompetence
right which could also be reflected in
juridical or traditional differences of
status and privilege right
differences
of other sorts he says each relationship
of power puts into operation differences
that are its conditions and its results
so the relationship between
a doctor and a patient is going to be
different than between a barber and
their client or a coach and their client
or we could go on and on and on right
and there's going to be multiple modes
of difference at
play the second thing that he says which
is quite different than this this is
teleological the types of objectives
pursued by those who act upon the
actions of others why
are they
acting on the actions of others
determining or conditioning or cajoling
or
whatever else we're going to say this
way
here's some examples foucault is not
intending to give us a complete list
maintenance of privileges right
sometimes we act just to like make sure
everybody knows their place
uh accumulation of profits we might want
to derive something from them exercise
of statutory authority the exercise of a
function or a trade maybe we're just as
we say doing our job right these are
objectives of the power
relations
another third thing
instrumental modes how do we
act upon the actions of others how do
others
act upon our actions
whether power is exercised by threat of
arms effects of speech through economic
disparities by more or less complex
means of control
systems of surveillance with or without
archives by rules explicit or not fixed
or modifiable with or without material
means of enforcement these again not an
exclusive or comprehensive list
but these give you an idea about what
the different instrumental modes
might be power is not always exercised
in exactly the same
way
then there are fourth forms of
institutionalization he says these may
mix traditional conditions legal
structures
matters of habit or fashion like in the
institution of the family
they can also take the form of an
apparatus closed in upon itself with its
specific loci its own regulations its
own hierarchical structures
for example scholastic or military
institutions
they can form very complex systems
endowed with multiple apparatuses like
the state
and and we're going to talk about the
state in just a little bit and then
finally we have fifth degrees of
rationalization
and he says that
the bringing of into play of power
relations as action in the field of
possibilities
may be more or less elaborate it's not
always the same thing right
in terms of the effectiveness of its
instruments the
instrumental modes
and the certainty of its results
or again in proportion to the possible
cost
the exercise of in of power he says is
not a naked fact an institutional given
nor is it a structure that holds out or
smashed it is something that is
elaborated transformed organized so
this makes things quite complex we need
to be attending to
all five of these whatever we want to
call them dimensions
aspects points to be established ways of
analyzing
power relations and there could be more
besides this this is just a perhaps
preliminary
list
and because of this he says
if you take this into consideration you
see why the analysis of power relations
within a society
cannot be reduced and this is typical
foucault right doesn't mean that you
can't study power by looking at these
things but it just can't be reduced to
just
these things so what are the these
things in this case
a series of institutions
or even to the study of the all those
institutions that would merit the name
political why
they are rooted in the entire network
of the social
now he says something really interesting
here as well he says
this doesn't mean that there can't be
some
loci of power or institutions that play
a greater role and the example that he's
going to focus on here
is the what he calls the state we would
think of it as the nation state but we
could also think of this in terms of
city management
and in terms of you know as we have here
in the united states particular states
um
federated system is is like that and he
goes on and he says that
it is certain that in contemporary
societies the state is not simply one
of the forms of specific situations of
the exercise of power even if it is the
most important but that in a certain way
all other forms of power relation must
refer to it now i think that applies
better to the french state than to some
other places uh which because the french
state is considerably more centralized
in that manner
than some others then he goes on and
says though
this is not because they the other forms
of power relation are derived from it
rather it's because power relations have
come more and more under state control
though the state control has not taken
the same form in pedagogical juridical
economic or family systems
so we could say power relations have
been progressively governmentalized
that is to say elaborated rationalized
and centralized in the form of or under
the auspices of state institutions
this is only a particular way of being
that applies to
you know late modernity though things
could be quite different and in fact may
be different even in our own time
than what foucault is diagnosing here
where the nation state or the state
has a centrality of reference
with power relations so this gives you
an idea about how foucault thinks power
relations
as
actions upon actions are to be analyzed
you